jaco i'm a high school teacher i
consider myself
the leader in the classroom how do i
demonstrate extreme ownership
in the classroom for example one of my
students misbehaves
how do i take extreme ownership of their
behavior
okay one way to do this and
i do this with my kids i did it with my
platoon guys
do it with jiu jitsu kids whoever
and what you do is you do exactly what
you're saying
you want to do which is you take
ownership so
what that means is you take ownership of
their behavior so
when something goes when the kids
misbehaving
you say hey what am i not making clear
to you
that you continue to act like this
because obviously i must be doing
something wrong because i'm the teacher
and you're in here acting like an idiot
and disrupting everything
what am i not doing well how could i
convey this message to you
that that you shouldn't act like that
not only that but how can i better
make you understand that what you do
right now is going to
affect and impact the rest of your whole
life
because i want you i'm supposed to
convey that to you as a person
that if you get engaged in class
you're going to have a more successful
and better life and that's what
my kind of goal is and so what i want to
know is how i can better explain to you
that your behavior while you're in here
from classroom attendance to having
big outbursts to skipping class to not
turning in
your homework to failing tests all those
behaviors
that you kind of display on a regular
basis i i
need to find a better way to explain to
you that the way you are acting right
now
will absolutely dictate where you're
going to be in the future
and it and by the way it's not a
positive thing
it's not a positive thing at all your
life is going in the wrong direction
and as a teacher i'm supposed to move it
in the right direction
so what do you think i could do better
to help you understand that
[Music]
so there we go that's that's that's one
method
and by the way i've used that with my
kids too that's a very effective method
for parenting is isn't why did you not
clean your room
it's how did i fail
as a father to it to
make you understand that basic
fundamental hygiene is a positive thing
[Music]
where did i where did i fail um and
that's
actually the cleaning room example isn't
a great one but when it's something a
little bit more
um severe than that it's not like when
they really do something
that's that's outside the lines right
and you say instead of saying you know
you went outside the lines you're messed
up
instead you say i'm sorry
that i couldn't convey to you the
importance of these lines
and why we don't go out them and now now
now i'm looking at you and i'm thinking
i don't know what mistakes i made
and i let you down as a father because
clearly you don't understand the
boundaries of
of what is good and what is bad and i
feel like i let you down
and that for my kids provokes a better
reaction than you that you screwed up
yeah yeah you screwed up um
now going on the other thing you can do
here
is you can explain how their behavior
affects and impacts everyone else in the
class and that
you as the teacher is not only
responsible for their behavior which you
are
but you're also responsible for teaching
every single person in the class
and and that you own that you own the
education of these other kids
and that you're not gonna let one kid
destroy the experience for everyone else
because that is not fair and you will
not do it i'm not gonna let that happen
i'm not gonna let you come in here and
impact all these other kids with your
negativity and your bad behavior
these kids are here to learn they
actually want to do something with their
lives
they want to take over and dominate they
want to win
and i'm looking at you and i think you
must want to lose because that's where
you're heading
that's what you want to do is lose in
life because these other kids they want
to win
so i'm not going to let that happen i'm
not going to let them lose because you
want to lose
if you want to lose you can go do it on
your own time in the principal's office
[Music]
and then you maybe you have to kick them
out of class maybe you have to suspend
them
for or whatever and
[Music]
i think that then you have to let people
understand that just like you take
ownership
they should take ownership of their
lives right that's the fundamental
thing that you're getting at and
lastly and this is something that i
think is very hard for young kids to
understand
young kids meaning the age is between
like 15 and
20 25 maybe even 25. some kids get it
earlier
you know some kids understand it earlier
but
understanding this thread of this this
thread of the passage of your life
and that the way that you act right now
yeah
affects the where you're going to be in
a week in a month a year
in five years and 10 years and kids do
not understand that they do not
understand
i didn't understand it when i was 10 12
18 30.
you know what i mean like well i think i
think actually one of the things one of
the best things for me
is that when you join the military they
they show you that threat
and it's very clear they're like hey you
do this and you get promoted you do this
and you get advanced you get this and
you get your paycheck you get this
oh and you do this other thing you don't
get a paycheck you didn't do this other
thing you go to the brig
yeah you do this other thing and you'll
you'll won't make it through seal
training yeah
so you know that was for me i shouldn't
have said get promoted because for me it
was
get to seal training and get through
seal training i didn't care about
getting promoted
i never did but to get when i was 18
years old
to get to seal training and to get
through seal training
that was a crystal clear path for me and
i saw it and as soon as i saw it i said
okay
i will not veer off that path what they
tell me to do i'll do
now there's nothing that's that solid
for a civilian
right for a civilian to say okay if you
do this right now you're going to get
into
this college yeah if you get into this
college and you get these kind of grades
you're gonna get this
kind of job there's no real clear path
like that and so
it's harder to draw that thread for
people but i think you can do it i think
you can show examples of
of of where you end up in the societal
structure based on your behavior as a
teenage person a teenage human yeah
yeah that's going to be hard just
straight up that's just going to be hard
for a teacher
because because of the time constraints
like that or the time
limitations you have with the with the
kid
yeah i think one thing that is i've done
with with my kids
is i look at other human beings in the
world with them
and i explain to them that that's a
person that's a person
i was talking about this with my son it
left such an impact on him
yesterday we were down at the beach
early morning one time years ago he was
probably
probably eight years old we were going
surfing waves were good by the way it
was a big day
hell yeah we got done and so now it's
7 30 8 o'clock in the morning and
there's a guy
that's a obvious drug
induced state of mayhem and he's got
five cops and they get him down and
we're watching this whole thing and he's
yelling
swearing and they they put a spit
bag on his head so he's just full-on
crazy
and you know my son saying what is that
dad you know it's like oh that's a spit
bag so that this guy doesn't spit on
these police officers that are down here
doing their job
and i said this is what happens when you
go on drugs
this is where you end up you end up with
no shirt on
one shoe a ripped jeans you you have a
spit
bag on your head you're handcuffed and
you're going to jail
that's where you end up that's where the
path leads so
don't do those things don't don't start
down that path
and it's the same thing you know as with
my daughter
and we saw what did we see
i was pointing out to her again someone
a woman that clearly didn't have a place
to live
um you know she was a homeless person
and
i you know walking with my daughter and
we see the woman with the shopping cart
and it's filled with you know
stuff you know crap and sleeping bags
and
cans and whatever clearly a homeless
person
but what was weird and the reason i
specifically point out was because she
looked somewhat
you know somewhat normal and
yet you could tell that she was not
doing well
and so you know i said to my daughter i
said
what do you think of of that person and
she
says i don't know what do you mean i
said well do you think that person
wants to be there and she said well
we'll know
i said well how do you think she ended
up there and she said i don't know
and i said you know i don't know i don't
know either but that's a real person
and when she goes to bed tonight she's
going to be underneath the bridge
somewhere
she's going to be cold she's going to be
wet she's going to be miserable
and that is how that's her life that's
where she ended up
so some choices that she made along the
way
may have contributed to that and what
i'm saying to you
is make choices that will contribute to
you
not ending up in that position because
those people that you see
that are homeless that are addicted to
drugs those people
are actually people and you can it's
very easy to view them as
oh i can never be there they're not
they're a different species
than me they're not that's
i guess that's the that's the point of
my story is that it's really easy
for people to look at other people and
think that's not i could never be there
that could not happen to me and my point
to my kids is
oh yes it can if you make the wrong
choices
hey you know what you could be bad luck
sure it could be bad luck
it can be bad luck but most of the time
the vast majority of time
it's decision making bad decision making
gets you in bad situations
and by the way people that
go off the path and and then they say
you know what
i screwed up i did
the wrong thing and i'm gonna now fix it
that's you don't see people like that
that are homeless you don't see people
like that that are addicted to drugs
because they take responsibility and
they say okay
i made this mistake i didn't do the
right things
i need to get fixed and they fix it
whereas
someone that says oh it's my parents
fault and it's my
boyfriend's fault and it's my
girlfriend's fault and it's my old
boss's fault
and it's my pusher's fault and whoever
you want to blame it's
if it's not your fault you don't you
don't fix the problem you don't take
ownership of the problem you don't fix
it on a personal level
and that's problematic yeah
your parents were teachers huh yes both
teachers
yeah makes that there's a lot of it
seems like there's a lot of similarities
with teachers and then parents right
because it's both like
you're both trying to guide these young
minds sure by the way
kids teenagers whatever yeah they can't
really have you know i say they don't
understand the correlation between like
their actions now
right right they they kind of can't
because that part of their brain isn't
developed yet it's the front part
frontal whatever it's called the front
part that's the front part
i think it's a medical term but it tends
to
on average or whatever developed by age
25 that's why i said
25 okay so that's typically you know
give or take when it when it's done
developing
so yeah before that and it's basically
the decision making like okay
just what you said what i do now affects
the future and you know like now you're
like oh
when you do something you can almost
feel the payoff in the future it's
almost like that you
understand it now back then you couldn't
that's why these colleges
when you go to college at 18 or 17 in my
case
they all all these credit card little
credit card pushers
they'll just post stuff outside of your
dorm room and be like hey un
unsecured i don't even know what
unsecured means by the way at this time
uh 300 limit just credits free money
free money that's how they do all you
got to do is fill out this thing and
everyone of course
of course i don't know what that means
i'll pay it back away later
so they get you like that but
nonetheless um yeah so they don't have
that part of their brain they
they don't know yeah so the the answer
is and i'm kind of
drawing from my childhood
so i had these two teachers right one
teacher his name was
mr tokita japanese guy and he was like a
little
samurai ninja guy he didn't really talk
that much
like outside of the classroom and when
he talked in the classroom it was all
deliberate stuff there was no small talk
it was really rigid we had a quiz every
single friday every single friday
ten questions real short quiz about the
weak stuff
his little lecture on the board was like
boom boom boom boom boom boom i think
he'd even underlined the key points you
know so you'd know
there was a there was no like hey read
this and i'm gonna test you no mystery
no mystery this is what you're gonna be
doing he underline the key points and
you gotta know those key points at the
end of the week
test every week boom you take or quiz
it's a quiz then there's a test on all
the stuff
whatever but you were not ill-equipped
for these tests you knew as long as
you're showing up paying attention you
knew
so either you did it or you didn't do it
you know so it was
and there was no like hey guys nothing
like you you knew what to expect this
guy was so consistent with every
every little thing all the way down to
the that like if you call them tokita
because sometimes that's how you know
when you get real chummy with it with
the teachers just in general if you're
that kind of person
you won't say mr or mrs right so some
everyone saw you'd be like
hey um i don't know smith we'll just say
if the teacher's name was mrs smith he'd
be like hey smith and you know it's
it's a kind of chummy relationship so
one time i forget who it was
it might have been this girl cressy
anyway because oh tequita because she
liked him
he was a likable guy that's a thing but
um but just
really consistent and rigid like a ninja
or something
and they were like hey tokita um and ask
a question
and he didn't get mad nothing like that
he just answers the quote real stoic
this answers the question
and as he's shuffling his papers like
this
just real like this guy was so oh cold
cold his ice guy he goes like this boom
he answers the question
and he goes and that's mr tokita and
then he just continues on right
and everyone's like dang that was
[__] awesome but
anyway i did the best in that class
because it was one of those things that
it was so consistent like there was no
room for slack if
if you slacked off it was really
apparent discipline equals freedom
yeah you know but he wasn't the kind
like he wouldn't yell at you it wasn't
that i don't yell
yeah so discipline equals freedom you
don't need to yell
when people understand expectations you
need to yell and the thing and you're
like this too where you're real
consistent
that's the thing too because you know
sometimes let's say you're real rigid
one
week and then the next yeah that's bad
or let's say you're you're really rigid
like the whole year
and then i don't know you're not you're
feeling i don't know you're hungover or
something
you partied or something you come to
class as the teacher by the way
um and then you're not as rigid that day
oh there's the little
there's the little [__] in your in your
armor there and they'll kind of start to
exploit it these kids
which brings me to my second teacher not
going to say his name he was in seventh
grade though
where this guy was just all over the
place super easy to take advantage of
this guy who's a music teacher wait
wasn't he major
music teacher yeah i think so i don't
know i forget but
super easy to take advantage of this guy
the kind like he loses
cool all the time and you know it was
just funny to see him react a lot of the
time
right and he the thing is he didn't
start like that he started just super
nice
just like hey the kind like people would
run over him and he'd be like hey
you know we don't have to he was just
super nice but he wasn't consistent with
anything
then after a while i think it was after
like a few years
um i hear that he's like really mean now
yeah like he loses his temper all the
time yeah i'm like what the heck
it goes it goes back to just discipline
equals freedom right yeah
if you would have held the line in the
beginning and said no
no you don't act like that in here stop
then
if you would have stopped at the minimal
or
at this small action
that was bad this small bad behavior if
he tightened that up then it would never
get to bid then he doesn't have to lose
his temper and get crazy
and i'm sure he's a nice guy i'm sure
he's a positive guy he had the highest
hopes and expectations
going back to the earlier subject he had
the really high hopes that everyone's
gonna be in here to learn and
and open their minds and and it's like
no these kids are in here to
shoot spit balls yeah and stick pencils
into the back of the person sitting in
front of them
right that's that's sort of it exactly
yeah that's sort of it
and when you realize that then you don't
allow that minimal behavior and then
they don't get totally out of control
yeah man hard work being a teacher very
much so
very much so because again like because
it goes back to that thing man where
where you only have like what an
hour or something 45 minutes yeah in
a day yeah and that's only for like five
days maximum for the week
sometimes less you know if you've got
holidays whatever and then they go home
or wherever and then they get their
influences you know boom boom as they
grow up then they come back to your
class with all that influence and it's
like what
what now you know and you got to kind of
find a way as a teacher
not only to like get through to them
just person to person but you got to get
them all this material
and if they don't like that material oh
man that's yet another task you know
so again man if you have that that
structure in place and it's consistent
and they know what to expect that's
going to help because they have this
scaffolding
they don't know how to make this you
know i got asked one time by a teacher
it's kind of a similar question you know
i've done everything to get through to
this person that
they're just not they're just not
getting in the game
what do i do now i was like well try a
different way
try try a different way you know you
didn't get through them that way tried a
different way
how can you get through them now just
like as a boss
as a leader as a platoon commander if
you've tried every single possible
different way and you've got someone
that just
cannot do it or does not want to do it
and they're negatively affecting
everyone else then it's your
responsibility as a leader to
get rid of them get rid of them
and had another conversation with a
teacher one time who had
kicked someone out of her school
for fighting and i
i and and this this person's a great
person
and a friend of mine she kicked someone
out of the school and
we met at a at a dinner and we were just
talking and i said oh how's everything
going she goes well you know i just
kicked this person out of school and i
was like oh what's the situation
and she's well you know it's this guy
this kid and
he's been a good kid he doesn't come
from a great home and but he got into a
fight he hit another kid and i just have
no
we can't have that at school at all and
so me being a jerk
i was like oh so you just destroyed his
his life basically
and she and you know and she's like what
do you mean i go well if the kid doesn't
have much of a home and he's not coming
from a great family the only thing he
has is your school
and if you don't allow him in school now
you kicked him out where's he gonna end
up i go
did you did you already open up a space
for him in prison somewhere
because that's where he's headed and i
was just i was i was being a total jerk
but i didn't really do this until i saw
her like getting emotional
and i was like oh i'm sorry and and so
then we had the conversation
and what was great was we talked
and and we went through this
conversation and
because what i was saying even though i
was being a jerk about it even though i
was being kind of
i don't know i wasn't being sarcastic i
was just being real uh really offensive
because she's a friend you know and we i
that's
this how i am like one of your steel
teams yeah exactly
treating her like another seal but then
we talked and i said look
but even though i'm i i don't mean to be
a jerk i'm
i'm i'm telling like what i believe to
be the truth cracking but
you have a great school you have this
great opportunity for these kids and
this
kid who has been well behaved was oh and
this was the other
critical part the kid that he got in a
fight with the kid that he punched he
sucker punched the guy not sucker punch
but
threw the first punch the other kid was
the class
jerk the class picking on people and
always misbehaving
that kid didn't get kicked out of the
school he wasn't going to get kicked out
of the school because he didn't actually
get involved in the physical violence
yeah and
and so then and i told her that too i
said look you got one kid
that he finally broke mentally
and you got another kid that just knows
how to push people's buttons and he
wanted him to hit him
and now you're kicking the kid out that
actually probably
should have done what he did that kid
probably deserved to get punched in the
face and
and anyways after this long conversation
you know she went back and the other the
other key
little thing that we talked about was i
i said it's okay
for you as the leader to say hey look i
made a mistake you know what i'm not
kicking him out of the school you know
why
because this other kid acted like a jerk
this other kid harassed him this other
kid did these other kid
things and this child has been a
well-behaved child
and he lost his temper and that's human
and we're going to keep him in the
school and she did that
so my point is
it's a hard job yeah and
yeah that's my point big time man and
that's
and that's another yet another thing
that i think
we got to balance this in regular
society too but it's
so this kid right for example your
example where the kid
punched a guy so boom we have this
incident so what do you do though right
it's like that's a problem if you in as
far as problem solving goes
you don't punish the kid you evaluate
what happened and then you
essentially help the kid so he doesn't
punch him right like some people they're
like hey we gotta punch this kid somehow
give him detention
or something and does that solve the
problem maybe yeah maybe we actually
teach someone to control their emotions
exactly right like why'd you punch him
oh because this guy did this okay
there's another problem by the way
so we gotta teach this kid to stop
messing around right
in that way you know and then we gotta
teach this kid okay if you get you get
messed around
you're right and sometimes the only way
some kids learn a lesson is by
being severely punished kicked out of a
school whatever you know
expelled or something like that but most
cases what most cases what does that
really teach them
that that school doesn't care about them
right so that's a tough situation
you know interestingly in way of the
warrior kid
the the next book that's coming out sure
the
whole and i'm not going to give the
whole story away but
the the opening chapter
young mark is in the principal's office
and he's in the principal's office
because he threw a paper mache
pumpkin at another kid's head
why did he do it because he was
frustrated because he got mad because
the kid was picking on him continually
uh verbalizing verbal abuse and finally
mark just got mad and he
hucked a paper mache pumpkin at the
kid's head
it bounced off the kid's head and hit
and hit this carpenter right in the face
too so he got sent to the office
but anyways but the point is where i the
reason i did that is because
kids that are 11 years old they still
lose their temper they haven't learned
to control their temper yet and so
one of the themes in the new warrior kid
book is that a warrior has to learn to
control their temper and control their
emotions
yeah the lessons that we're talking
about right now yeah interestingly
enough
so thanks to the teachers out there big
time man because man as a tea
and i've never been a teacher obviously
but
i mean just even halfway imagining it
man you kind of care about like these
kids but you care about them all
so and then you have all this the whole
spectrum of them you have the kid who's
like
ooh the teacher's pet as far as the
other kids are concerned but meanwhile
you love that kid
cause man he's picking up what you're
putting down and he's listening
he's giving you apples and whatnot then
you have on the other side you have the
one that won't listen to anything
disrupting your class you know
but you want that kid like of course you
want to leave you like stop
messing up my whole thing but you want
to be successful yeah man because like
when you you know how you teach someone
something
and you see them use it oh man that's
the best as any kind of teaching
capacity that you know as far as the
role that you play like in jiu jitsu or
something like that
even like another adult because it's all
the same right actually
i think kids well there's like there's a
fundamental human characteristic i
believe that makes you want to help
other people
yeah it feels like you're
on or gonna influence like that i don't
know maybe but man so it's like
this it's like yet that's yet another
thing you got to deal with as a teacher
you know because you're committed man
it's like